2500 tonnes d'ordures jonchent en ce
moment les rues de marseille les
éboueurs ont arrêté leur travail le 29
novembre dernier suite à une demande de
leur direction de travailler davantage
cette semaine l'ensemble des syndicats
ont trouvé un accord avec la métropole
notamment sur la base d'une
revalorisation salariale
mais force ouvrière le syndicat
majoritaire estime insuffisante cette
compensation il appelle à la poursuite
du mouvement de grève donc ce qu'on leur
demande en fait c'est travailler donc
comme je vous le disais
[Musique]
plus pratiquement un tiers de temps plus
que ce qui se passe qu'est ce qu'il
faisait avant avec
un salaire qui n'augmentent pas donc
très concrètement c'est facile de
comprendre que quand on demande de
travailler plus sans augmenter les
salaires ça veut dire concrètement
contre conques en perdent du salaire ou
qu'on travaille pour rien donc c'est ça
qui n'est pas acceptable malgré le refus
de force ouvrière de signer l'accord de
nombreux agents ramasse déjà les ordures
suite à la décision de la préfecture des
bouches du rhône de réquisitionner les
agents dans le même temps des sociétés
privées ont été sollicités pour pallier
les nombreux arrêts maladie poser ces
derniers temps si le conflit social n'a
pas encore trouvé d'issue les rues de la
métropole sauront-elles nettoyer